okay it's Thursday which means we do
have jobs numbers in the last week 1.5
million more people have lost their jobs
remember that this is once again a
number that before the coronavirus era
would have been twice the single week
new unemployment claim record which was
about 700,000 prior to coronavirus in
one week we have blown that out of the
water for 13 straight weeks now record
job losses peaking of course with 6.8
million people losing their jobs in one
week in late March then we saw declining
to 5 million 4 million a week 3 million
2 million the last couple of weeks about
one and a half million people each week
lost their jobs so this brings the total
number of jobs lost during coronavirus
to just over 45 million now to put that
number in context before the virus
pandemic started the workforce was
believed to be a hundred and fifty eight
million people 45 million jobs have been
lost during this pandemic in 13 weeks
and that is about 28 percent of the
total u.s. workforce now it's very
important to know and I have no interest
in hiding from you obviously that some
of the people who lost their jobs have
already found new jobs so if you want to
find good news or maybe not terrible
news the job losses are decelerating
meaning each week we have fewer people
losing their jobs that's good would be
better but to completely turn it around
we also maybe most importantly are
seeing that the last two weeks more
people found jobs in other words they
went back to work compared to the number
of people who lost their jobs so like
even though in the last week 1.5 million
more people lost jobs slightly more than
that went back to work so the total
number of active unemployed people
actually went down it's a very small
change we went from 20 point six million
unemployed to twenty point five million
unemployed okay so that's important now
to say it a different way 45 million
people
we'll have lost jobs during the pandemic
but 20 million are currently unemployed
meaning a large number of people have
gone back to work now what's the obvious
problem the problem is we're in the
middle of a pandemic I know that Donald
Trump is pretending as though the
pandemic is over a lot of red states are
pretending as though the pandemic is
over we're going to hear in the
voicemail segment today from someone
living in Hawaii but we are still in the
middle of a pandemic the job losses are
slowing down which is good but the
pandemic is raging and it's actually
worse than it has ever been in many
states so here in the United States
overall we are still finding about
20,000 cases a day the last few days
it's been more like twenty-two
twenty-three twenty-four thousand cases
the seven-day average of new cases is
going up actually and it has been going
up for ten days but then you look at
specific states you look at Texas you
look at Florida you look at Arizona and
other states they're spiking
dramatically and they appear to be
nowhere near their peaks so look at the
context right
if these job jobs numbers that we are
seeing now are starting to be less bad
because some states are totally wide
open but coronavirus is still raging we
have one of two possible futures jobs
continue to get less bad as way more
people die from coronavirus right we are
to open the jobs improve but deaths
absolutely get disastrously worse or we
are going to have to shut down again at
least some states are going to have to
shut down again and we are going to see
the jobs numbers get worse again now
we've seen some states like Texas Texas
is seeing this this is the worst week
since the beginning for Texas Texas has
made it pretty clear under their
Republican governorship that they don't
have an appetite to close down again
they seem to be taking the approach of
it's gonna be what its gonna be
protect yourselves if you don't want to
go out don't go out but we're opening
and we're going to be staying opening
what is becoming very clear is until you
have a really effective treatment and/or
vaccine you can
have both a serious jobs recovery and
limit spread because some stuff needs to
remain closed some stuff needs to remain
closed I'm hopeful that here in
Massachusetts because we've gone slowly
we have a very moderate Republican
governor here he could have acted a
little more quickly early on Charlie
Baker but he widely has done a good job
we've gone the the planning has been
phased and the phasing has been planned
as I like to say and we have gone step
by step and it's a slower recovery but
the point is that hopefully it's a more
permanent recovery that will get us to
have some degree of economic recovery up
to the point at which we have a vaccine
and/or effective treatment effective
treatment excuse me and in some states
they are not taking precautions and
they're pretending everything's fine and
so while their jobs recovery may have
been faster in the immediate their
coronavirus cases and eventually deaths
are going to get really really bad and
we would expect to see that probably by
the end of next week you would see a lot
of the cases from early this week start
tragically translating to death so we're
going to follow it